con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la frontera Colombo
venezolana a un mes de lo que fue el
protocolo de reapertura y no se reportan
cambios significativos también nos
acompaña en este momento Daniela Blandón
nuestra periodista de economía que
estuvo Precisamente en este cubrimiento
especial que hicimos aquí en Francia 24
En esta reapertura si se puede decir así
de la frontera Colombia venezolana y
nuestro invitado el día
xiomain las Heras ley sola él es
investigador adscrito al observatorio de
Venezuela de la Universidad del Rosario
y el presidente de la asociación diálogo
ciudadano Colombo venezolano semen
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 buena
mañana de miércoles Muchísimas gracias
Raúl un placer estar con ustedes también
es Daniela con nosotros en la mesa de
trabajo como la estábamos presentando y
Quiero preguntarle entonces para dar un
poco de contexto un mes y que ha pasado
no
Bueno quería empezar diciendo bueno que
a mí me parece un hecho positivo
efectivamente que la fronteras hay
abiertos sobre todo para las poblaciones
que que hacen bien en la frontera creo
que es un hecho básicamente positivo y
en general pues para para para para
ambos países para el comercio para
incluso para los para los migrantes no
sin embargo lo que hemos visto en este
primer mes es que el entusiasmo inicial
que había mostrado ambos gobiernos no
con los efectos positivos que iba a
traer esta reapertura nos ha dado por lo
menos en la en el nivel digamos de
entusiasmo que que había no
Aparentemente el intercambio que ha
habido hasta ahorita en la frontera de
carácter comercial ha sido un
intercambio menor están hablando en un
30 días de
67 camiones crees o da un promedio de
poco más de dos camiones por día y los
montos que han hablado básicamente al
gobierno colombiano porque el venezolano
poco se sabe digamos a nivel de cifra
pero las cifras que ha dado el gobierno
colombiano son unas cifras de una
cuantía no tan no tan importante
entonces creo que es entusiasmo se ha
rebajado era algo era algo previsible
creo que había mucho digamos un poco de
propaganda en ese en eso anuncio
iniciales Pero bueno creo que Esto va a
ser un proceso va a ser un proceso a
mucho más largo plazo de lo que se venía
diciendo en los anuncios al comienzo
Yo estuve allá en la frontera ese 26 de
septiembre y la gente como usted lo dice
pues estaba muy emocionada por lo que
iba a pasar pero más que todo por los
anuncios que se hicieron en ese momento
el presidente Gustavo Petro dijo que en
las próximas semanas se iba a abrir el
puente de tienditas también a mí había
mucha expectativa sobre la apertura del
transporte
particular que ha pasado con eso y
además con los vuelos que en ese momento
se anunció que se iban a reabrir los
vuelos y hasta el momento parece que no
ha habido mayores avances Bueno yo creo
que aquí hay un factor que no se
consideró igual suficientemente al
comienzo
Y es que en Venezuela es un país que
sigue confrontando problemas muy grande
y que tiene un nivel de de
institucionalización muy importante no
Entonces reanudar digamos toda la
relación implica por ejemplo a nivel
comercial reactivar aduanas todo el tema
fitosanitario todo el tema de impuestos
por ejemplo no y en un país que
confrontan los graves problemas que
confronta Venezuela pues esto no es un
tema fácil de solucionar y creo que es
una barrera importante para que esto
avance mucho más rápido No en el caso
colombiano es un país que está pues
mucho más preparado en ese sentido está
mucho más potente económicamente tiene
mucha más oferta digamos exportable que
que ofrecer verdad y tiene una
institucionalidad también que funciona
no es curioso que los reportes que hemos
escuchado indican que todavía se sigue
utilizando mucho las trochas pero si
están abiertos los los pasos regulares
es un poco contradictorio que las
truchas te sigan utilizando y no sé es
un tema todavía que creo que hay que
investigar lo que hizo un poco más pero
podría indicar que toda la trama digamos
ilegal que dominaba todo el paso
fronterizo sigue de alguna manera
generando más incentivos para que el
paso por ejemplo de mercancías etcétera
se produzca por esta vía y no por la por
las vías regulares no
insisto Esto va a ser quizá una cosa que
en el tiempo es donde se irá poco a poco
regularizando si los incentivos que se
dan para que el paso regular por la
frontera sean mayores que los incentivos
digamos por los por los pasos
irregulares hablando de esos pasos
irregulares sí sin duda es algo que
evidentemente tiene que atacar tanto el
gobierno colombiano como el gobierno
venezolano porque también precisamente
ese mismo día el presidente Gustavo
Petro en su discurso que dio En este
acto protocolario de una reapertura de
la frontera dijo que incluso
funcionarios o venezolanos estaban
involucrados en todas estas mafias
evidentemente que hay por las trochas
para que la gente va a pasar sobre todo
la mercancía no entonces evidentemente
la seguridad también es un punto
importante para que se dé toda esta
reapertura no también hacía referencia a
funcionarios venezolanos trabajando en
estas mafias Entonces evidentemente es
un proceso que debe ser bastante largo
para tratar de sanear todas estas áreas
Sí así es hay un dato hace poco una una
amiga que vino a Colombia desde
Venezuela que vino por tierra me
indicaba que en el camino entre Caracas
y Cúcuta pasó por 13 alcabalas con
diferentes cuerpos de seguridad
en poco traspasemos esto al comercio así
si una un una mercancía colombiana que
tiene que llegar al centro de Venezuela
tiene que pasar por 13
alcabalas de seguridad pues eso no es
ningún incentivo para el comercio para
el comercio formal no Entonces esto nos
da una idea las dificultades digamos que
se encuentran y luego hay un hecho
fundamental en Venezuela es un país
todavía en crisis económica importante
la capacidad de consumo que tiene el
país no es persona que tenía hace 20
años cuando el comercio entre Colombia y
Venezuela florecía y llegó a niveles de
siete mil ocho mil millones de dólares
luego también la capacidad que tiene la
industria venezolana de ofrecer
productos para exportar también se ha
disminuido mucho sí Venezuela tiene
grandes problemas y esta renovación de
relaciones no se da entre dos países en
condiciones digamos iguales así la
economía venezolana hoy en día pues
puede tener el tamaño de la economía de
Paraguay probablemente no Entonces esto
Esto es también un obstáculo adicional
para que este comercio sea mucho más
activo por lo menos en el corto plazo 13
puestos de control que evidentemente la
gente tiene que pagar dinero para poder
pasar Daniela y también otra sobre lo
que estaba diciendo me parece importante
como saber qué es Cuáles son esos
productos entonces que estamos
comerciando porque dos camiones diarios
no son mucho que es lo que le puede
ofrecer hoy Venezuela Colombia porque
entiendo que Venezuela más a Colombia de
lo que Colombia están viendo a Venezuela
sí ha habido en esto ha habido poco
información bastante confusa Y a veces
creo que hay A veces creo que
contradictoria no la información ha
venido más del lado del lado colombiano
que bueno como dijo como dije pues tiene
una institución de día más más fuerte y
y por ejemplo los ministros el ministro
de comercio a dar alguna alguna
información toda la información que ha
habido sobre Qué productos no a veces
depende De dónde viene la información
pues es como contradictoria a mí me
suenan algunas cosas raras estaba
escuchando que Venezuela estaba
exportando carbón y Colombia es un país
exportador de exportador de Carbón
entonces me suena un poco me suena como
contenido decía Bueno qué es esto esto
era un poco raro Luego también estaba
Leí algo de que se está exportando
aluminio y y hierro
si Venezuela reactiva porque eso está
totalmente parado en Venezuela en la
industria del aluminio que fue
importante en algún momento
significaría Apagar del todo a Venezuela
que ya está muy muy en penumbra porque
se necesita mucha electricidad para
producir aluminio entonces me parece muy
raro que se esté exportando aluminio
aluminio a lo mismo pasa con productos
siderúrgicos no Entonces yo creo que
hace falta todavía más transparencia eh
Y saber bien exactamente con
estadísticas claras de los ministerios
de ambos gobiernos que se está moviendo
nos estamos viendo en la frontera se han
dicho algunas cosas pero que lucen muy
extrañas y que además para finalizar ya
Se abrieron nuevas rutas aéreas digamos
y autorizaron para más aerolíneas Y
todavía las que están utilizadas pues la
han salido entonces muchas cosas por
esperar que pasen realmente trae este
proto